hey how are you hi I'm great how are you
good so what's uh so what's happening
what's going wrong
so it I actually love this topic because
I feel you know you've been talking
about because I definitely feel like
especially in the dating world
you know being a 31 year old woman that
takes care of myself I find that I look
significantly younger than my other 31
year old counterparts and I think there
is this false machismo that it is seen
as feminine to take care of yourself and
that's just simply not the case as
someone that values self-care is one of
my like core values right I want someone
who also feels the same way and a man
who
values himself enough to take care of
himself why would it be seen as feminine
if a guy takes care of himself like we
talk like I see there's there's no ads
running encouraging guys to wear makeup
right which sounds like the feminine
angle to me but why is what you take and
how you manage your hormones and your
blood and all that stuff like why would
that be considered feminine I don't
think that
that time you guys find it to be
feminine is that why they've got an
inversion to it I think I think maybe
it's maybe something that they learned
from their fathers they don't want to
some older Generations who feel like oh
I can fix it myself I can do it myself
you know miss me with that
um you know men don't have seem to have
a skincare routine they don't want to
wear sunscreen
um
like that just seems and it's and it's
unfortunate because you know I think
it's important for if a man values
himself to take care of himself
appropriately right and how are you
supposed to take care of someone else if
you can't take care of yourself so
are you familiar with sunscreen
ingredients
and I wouldn't say that
I and what sort of sunscreen you know
did you go for
usually like the all-natural ones you
know when you talk about like
um some of the cancer causing
ingredients and things like that you
know you try to do something more
natural well but they're not that's the
thing though because I mean if you I
mean if you just want to talk about
sunscreen as like a skin care routine
and a topic that guys need to sort of
contemplate
um the ingredients and the vast majority
of sunscreens are uh estrogenic right
they have either oxybenzone or a version
of oxybenzone I can't remember what the
first three characters are but it still
ends in basically z benzone
um it's the same product that does the
same thing in the body which converts to
estrogen and they find that it stays in
your body for up to a week
um the only sunscreen that you should
wear if you're going to wear sunscreens
is from the topic is zinc based that's
it the the medical ingredient is zinc
and guess what you're going to look like
Casper the Friendly Ghost when you put
it on probably but that's the only thing
you can put on your skin that will lower
the effect of the UV rays and uh not let
you burn without converting the estrogen
in your body so like there's a lot of
things guys don't even contemplate like
most guys will wear sunscreen I'm
actually at the point where what I'll do
is I barely even wear sunscreen because
if I have to wear it it's going to be
the zinc base and it'll just look like
white paste so I just tend to go out
more in the morning and in the late
afternoon until I have a tan and they
don't even have to bother wearing
sunscreen you know unless it's a hat or
a shirt or something like that most of
the sunny days and I get a nice tan you
know the summer and I don't use
sunscreen at all for anti-aging I don't
have a lot of wrinkles for my age Okay
so
the notion of of like
um skin cares and stuff like that like
there's some good skin care products I
think the peptide based ones uh I
actually have a tab open over here I
open it because I meant to talk about it
but there's
um let me share this here real quick
because this is the only one that I
would recommend the guys use
um this is the one that I use which is
um it's on a website called
a Seer custom aseir custom.com
um they're not paying me to say this
there's no affiliate link or anything
like that but this is the one that I use
over here it's uh and it's a peptide
based one and the reason why I got into
it I learned about this stuff is because
apparently Fighters use it to repair
their skin from Battle damage from
fights to help the cuts and the bruises
and all this sort of stuff so this
company figured that out and they put it
into a skincare product which helps you
know that issue with collagen all that
stuff especially you also have to take
collagen in too like as you get older
one of the things I've done in the last
couple years is I've is I've started
taking more collagen either in protein
shakes or I'll put them in my coffee in
the morning
um but I probably have like 30 40 grams
of collagen a day now which is super
useful as far as Skin Care Now
I wouldn't go telling guys to put on
sunscreen or just buy some skincare
stuff because most of the stuff is legit
[__] like if you go to most like
whenever I go shopping with my kid you
know she'll pick something up and she'll
be like Daddy you know can I buy this
and I'm looking at I'm like read how
many ingredients are on this can you
find something with like three or four
ingredients please like 32 doesn't work
sort of thing right so these are some
conversations that you're going to have
to have as far as you know guys that
you're dealing with are they just
laughing at this you know when it comes
to the conversation of self-care and
taking care of themselves
um I think yeah I I think when I bring
it up and I I think when I bring it up
and I make it like a like an okay space
for them to talk about like no you know
no one's ever talking about this before
I didn't really see the value I think
most people come most men come around to
it but they don't have any formal
education in it because of how I think
Society has it perceived to or has kind
of related to them and that's really
unfortunate because I think they want to
take care of themselves but because they
feel
some level of like a barrier to entry
there I think that there's I think
lowering that barrier to entry for them
would be really really helpful because
it's unfortunate because I think them
wants to take care of themselves they
just simply don't know how or have the
tools
well I mean
people usually only go looking for help
when it comes to help like they would
rather have a prescription than they
would a uh nutraceutical that prevents
the issue right like they'd rather go to
the doctor and get a pain pill than to
take a vitamin
right I think women tend to be more
proactive like women tend to be
proactive in our anti-aging approach and
as such
collagen disappears from your skin a lot
faster in women than it does from uh men
right so you really have to be on that
stuff early I think women should
contemplate this stuff in their 20s for
sure yeah and start a good you know like
routine or whatever that happens look
like and I think most women figure that
out by their by their 20s anyway when
you know the first gray hair pops and
the first wrinkle sort of happens around
the side but guys need to pay attention
to this stuff too and it's like look I
mean
I don't blame you for not being
interested in guys that don't prioritize
self-care if it's something that's
priority for you
um you should be Discerning in your
taste in that regard because you know
women always want the best that they can
get anyway right so why would you want a
guy that's a bum that doesn't take care
of himself when you could if there's
guys out there that do right so it's
absolutely fine how do you motivate more
guys to take their you know their health
and their aging more seriously
like I said they'd rather have a
painkiller than a vitamin you know like
the guys will go looking for
statins and cholesterol meds and all
that stuff like that rather than change
their diet
yeah we are
yeah do you have a better solution
well oh I'm a personal trainer and a
coach so I do a lot of like like
coaching for people who have actively
sought out my health yeah
um when it comes to dating I offer a lot
of unsolicited advice
um but people are usually receptive to
if you if you are kind enough but I
think doing what you're doing right now
is really awesome I think that putting
the content out and having more
conversations about it and about men
taking care of themselves you know
instead of being in these Martyrs of
hard work and uh self-deprecation you
know there's a lot of
there's a lot of that
I want to I want to make sure I
articulate this well
I get a lot of messages when people when
men see my career and they're like oh I
am looking for someone to motivate me
I'm looking for someone to get me back
in the gym I'm looking for someone to do
this I'm like I'm so sorry you're gonna
have to do it all on your own how how
unattractive is that to you when you
hear that
oh it's an immediate like I I can't I'm
it's gross right like you know it's so
icky somebody's saying to you I need I
need somebody to motivate me will you
motivate me like lower your standards
and take care of my fat ass basically is
what they're saying and as someone who's
career it is to do that it's like okay
well you can pay my session rate if
you'd like a problem correct yeah no
problem here's my here's my card no
problem yeah isn't that interesting
mm-hmm
um I think men want help but I think
that there is this you know low
activation for them and what is your
what is your number one recommendation
for men you know since we have you on
you know when it comes to self-care
try
do something I think preventative
preventative is number one but if you
have if you have missed that boat
um the resources that you have
supplementation and getting your diet
and exercise back in like muscle mass
exercise is the number one anti-aging
that's if you wanna if you want to look
and feel better move your body
yeah that's an excellent point I want to
emphasize that because I didn't because
I didn't state that earlier
um having lean muscle on your body as
you get older is incredibly important
for so many different functions in your
body it's uh it's not just useful for
strength and for moving around but it
but it's actually almost like a fuel you
know as you get older like your body
needs it
as you get older
there's a
yeah it's hard to maintain there was a
um and you might have to fact check me
on this but I think that there was
something recent where you talked about
muscle as an endocrine organ
where muscle releases more like hormones
now and so we talk about regulating your
hormone function and being able to
age appropriately as your hormone
function gets a little bit more wonky uh
muscle is really really powerful in
helping to regulate that
yeah it's
it's definitely useful lean muscle mass
so there's your so there's your advice
guys don't be uh fat and lazy be uh big
and jacked and you will age better trust
me
um you know you take care of your body
it's it's going to pay back dividends
you don't like I'm telling you guys I'm
telling you I look around when I train
when I go to the gym when I'm out in
public and there's some people out there
that don't have to love the way that
they look and I know that they're
I don't want to say in pain but they're
uncomfortable going up the stairs
reminds them that they're getting older
you know getting out of a chair reminds
them that there's that there's things
falling apart with their body and it
happens more and more as they get older
and you don't and you don't have to deal
with that you really don't
that's my advice Liz thanks for chiming
in I appreciate it appreciate you all
right take care I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out